[Music]
in cyber banging news cyber banging
you'll see ok you [ __ ] over the camera
no no submitted by handcrafted artistry
New York gangbangers are using mo G's as
a secret language to plan crimes did you
say mo G's emojis okay yeah did that
call emojis I'm just checking cuz I
don't know I don't ever send mugs you're
probably cool with me so I'm like if
that's what they call them and I don't
think of that generation I like that
gang signs that's right you're saying
you emoji so like if I send you this
that means I'm a member of the Harlem
Crips no way are you kidding seriously
mm Sarla cool is incredible we could
just read this article
not even react to it and it's funnier
than probably anything we'll come on cuz
of all I'm begging to
in 1997 when a law came out there would
be gang
chat rooms and people would type in
their gang names in the chat rooms and
gang bang on the chat rooms have you
guys ever been bang done on the chat
rooms no like just in person all the
time right we grew up in a 99 like say
like what be like where are you from say
they're gay yeah I had a [ __ ] bottle
of Snapple bottle thrown at me like
whatever little boys alright see you I
got banged on recently brittle [ __ ] I've
never been banged um so when someone
said where are you from you're like
actually from Florida no no it wasn't
even that it was I got introduced to the
I went to a [ __ ] comedy club why would
you do such a thing
well first of all I was going my friend
and you want red and you were like this
is a good I just like have just like
this as a proper color so like hold on a
crib comedy club coming cuz I they like
to laugh so much they like to laugh like
first of all the comedy was the rawest
thing I've ever heard but the the head
comic was he came up to me and he was
like hey wassup homie you viral
no way he's a I said you viral my home
he said we need to work together you
viral Wow so he basically gangbanged on
your his collaboration about you I don't
homie viral I say what you kind of
should not I was she shoot videos that
my friend was like now he's a director
rings like alright we should work
together you know as a matter of fact
you gonna see what I'm about and he
would I bust a just started doing his
jokes and I was like yo this is was he
funny he's hilarious
oh good he's hilarious but he some of
the jokes were just like very aggressive
dude you feeling you're obligated to
laugh because he was banging on you
earlier I hope you didn't target me
because he he'd say some stuff he'd be
like what's one thing he said sure you
can say it or you can say it
he was like he's like how you doing
that's why [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] me I'm not
talking about you the [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
you know saying you said like I was I
was like yo like he's like pulling
people on the spot and just like he was
like he's always gonna crowd work yeah
the first jump inside he was like he
said alright how many [ __ ] in here
suck my dick
damn did you hear any a pause do it it
was sunny he's like yeah young y'all
good y'all y'all real attentive me my
baby moms in here right now so I'm glad
you're in class I was like where the
[ __ ] in my hair I said where is the joke
man
there's just all rhetorical questions
yeah
on the record I think that guy's
hilarious he was always good so here in
New York gangs right when when you like
I said texting to thumbs-up that means
you're part of the crabs what the Harlem
Chris okay and police have have honed in
on exactly what they're doing basically
all these gangs have turned to emojis
not so that when they're communicating
via text and [ __ ] they don't get flagged
like for furtive the cops to start
snooping on what they're doing so some
of this [ __ ] dude I'm not even kidding
one of these if it it wouldn't the two
thumbs up thing resembles the letter H
that means that's the Harlem Crips one
right yeah you put the Bloods the Bloods
single their affiliation with the image
of a magician's top hat yeah well I
thought they were gonna choose like this
isn't nurse is their syringe with one
yeah did use blood or I never move that
one just like the red yes this is a red
stripe maybe no but the but word where
do they post this like on forms and
stuff and I focus to each other but I
don't know you just get a text the top n
that means what we're gonna have a gang
conversation now like when you know who
who's in your phone is part of the game
hot topic we know this guy
like what I think it might be a
Instagram and Twitter and stuff like
that they're just tweeting at them and
saying so what two thumbs up so what
they do is man they use the emojis they
post other gang symbols upside down as a
sign of disrespect
right so you so instead of having the
top hat up right as it should be it's
now upside down so they Photoshop
Photoshop it that makes me so mad this
respectful finding worries both of them
have it post guys they also and I swear
this is not a troll they also live
stream video from their opponents turf
on snapchat which is a type of taunting
known as cyber bang like I'm in your
hood right now look at this exactly and
then with the top hat I mean your
territory
hotham Crips look
I look like Abraham Lincoln in your hood
top it upside down [ __ ] you
wow they're calling it sucker banging
we're really it's just cyberbullying
because this is how they game bang with
tagging they'll write like they're the
the rival gang like upside down they
would cross them out they would do all
that stuff so now they're doing it with
tech that's crazy
yes gangs gangs learn to avoid Facebook
they now call it fedebook because every
time that they talk on there they feel
like the feds were listening Wow so now
they prefer whatsapp cover me and ki
messenger unencrypted and an app called
you Bo which is a dating app marketing
to teens and that that's where their
messages quickly disappear yeah fedebook
is what the Cole Facebook mass so WAP
into the old-fashioned like fighting and
shooting and stuff and stabbings that
was just that's mean that's bullying
they don't do that anymore if you put
stickers on people now I feel like they
do that but then now they use technology
to like find out where their enemies are
like if they're like geo-tagging and
then they can like figure out where
they're out and then they can [ __ ]
fight or some [ __ ] I don't know I'd be
great do they have their own snapchat
like sticker filters that would be even
better
no our face filters like you look like a
wolf or something yeah like Instagram
you can make your own filters now right
yeah I think so what about your own gifs
right you could type in like [ __ ] or
blood and then just like a guy like
[ __ ] soup dog going like this or
something - only Snoop Dogg you require
krippgive well gangs need social media
managers what I minded but yeah is this
an untapped market
I think so so cops are saying that it's
actually pretty smart because with
whatsapp the minute you delete it from
your phone it's actually gone so they
just pretty much just positively
reinforced all the Gators you got - did
a good job with you guys erased - what's
that so that means that they follow each
other because if he's like taunting them
on snapchat then that means yet to have
like rival followers yeah you need their
number for what that you're getting the
word though you're getting the word out
and then they also use all this stuff to
recruit other gang members hmm I wonder
if there's like famous like influence or
gangsters now he's gotta be yeah I just
don't know you know so they're going
around and he's like who's the most
gripping of them all and then it's like
five five three [ __ ] guy
Compton or something and then he's like
his instagrams like him with his bandana
and all that and he has like a million
followers and maybe yeah do well and
apparently one of the ways that they
jump you into a game now is they they
take all the Pokemon that you've gotten
on Pokemon go and they send them to each
other
damn you lost your right here no I'm
sure they empty your entire crypto your
entire pokedex so now you got to rebuilt
the whole thing look I was pretty sure I
was gonna I was like I'm gonna be the
king we can start our own game right now
everyone share your Pokemon you'd be the
leader a better one would have been like
they start Kickstarter accounts and you
have to fund X amount of dollars or some
[ __ ]
they'll be crazy or they empty out your
vem oh wow so in one so apparently
they're also expanding in the game
consoles this is true ok game console
game consoles so in one robbery a [ __ ]
set up a cell phone while chatting via
PlayStation and when the victim showed
up so it's like I want to sell a cell
phone right and then the the victim
shows up someone pulls a gun on my Robin
oh that's like those Craigslist
Craigslist yeah just set up while
chatting on PlayStation instead Wow
oh so like on PlayStation don't hey you
want any live stream is no no they go
into the chats on does anyone want to
buy a cell phone wanna buy a [ __ ]
game console one of my sneakers
headphones too good to be true man no
one knows when the Pokemon go yeah the
thing was happening the craziest
happening a lot of Pokemon go people
were getting jumped by people like what
they would kind of walk into the wrong
neighborhoods and stuff they were
walking in gang territory cuz there was
gang game dude
yep man that must have been so
interesting there's just like all these
nerds me like we can't go to that part
we do it I really want that Pikachu dude
yeah but there's an arrow that tall over
there
Dragonite I need you dragon a way to
suck into the game there's a rare shine
he over there I remember when that game
first came out I was in India for my
cousin's wedding and my little my cousin
was like let's go let's go across the
street I'm like I can't [ __ ] across the
street here there's about there's like a
hundred million people that are gonna
jump us if we try to get this Pokemon do
you when you go visit you don't go
outside into the streets and stuff no I
do all the time it's like one of those
things where my mom's like don't go
outside I'm like I'm a grown man but
it's crazy it's just crazy because I
mean it's fine let's do it it's fine hey
just cuz I'm a foreigner and they know
immediately yeah so everyone tries to
say I'm the [ __ ] they just know cuz I'm
like a haircut or clothes I'm wearing
they just know there's no stains on his
shirt yeah zero yes that's like how you
were in Japan you said everyone knew
you're American oh yeah they know they
know me the way you talk the way your
body your body lay to much protein on
his friend and upbringing the body
language is totally different I'm also
just in awe because everyone's brown
which I'm not used to seeing I'm like oh
my god I'd be scared of
don't be twenty guys holding hands with
machetes that are like trying to rob me
so yeah then NYPD is basically saying
that parents if you're watching this
which you're not but easily the main way
to to monitor all this [ __ ] is to just
try to watch your kids phones because
cops can't even check out what's going
on without a court order
so these guys have really figured out a
way to recruit gangbang all this [ __ ]
using phones using throwaway apps and
there's no way to catch them I'm never
having kids right you don't want to
build an army do of your children I
don't know what we do though you doesn't
have a purpose for the army you do you
have plans
[Music]
[Music]